always uh watch the tyson uh i want to
talk to you about this tyson
oh uh he was on stage when it was going
on
when the main in the main did you see
the rules though
that's what me okay what was that yeah
it's strange because like all my like
peers who do the same [ __ ] i do
are all like that was dope this is this
this is this
and i'm below the belt my thing is like
how long do we pretend that that was
dope
yeah that was not dope that was some
[ __ ] it was cool that mike tyson got
in shape
but it was there's a gentleman's bet
there's no really hidden to the head
and that if it depends what frame of
mind you went into watching the fight so
let's say your dad who's not on social
media or anything when it was like dude
tyson about to rip roy a [ __ ]
you know he said tear his hat off yeah
if you're in that mind frame you'd be so
disappointed
because before this fight when this
fight got announced shortly after andy
foster who's the head of the california
commission went
this ain't a real fight charity it's an
amateur fight there's bigger gloves
uh you know we give them a choice to
wear headgear there's gonna be no
knockouts no knockdowns
and they can't go too hard if they do
we're gonna intervene and make sure
they're not going too hard
really and then that got out and then
the neighbor was like [ __ ] this i'm not
buying this
and then that's when mike tyson roy
jones started coming out be like no
no no no we're going to tear each
other's head off like this can be dope
but we're going to do this this
i'm scared and they start releasing
these training videos really got the
public back into it
so then when you watch it and you don't
get a real fight and there's a draw
it's just like it was a gentleman's bat
it was like you know how it is like
in boxing i'm sure like roy jones was
the perfect
candidate for mike tyson because he was
like take this fight you can get three
mil you'll probably get some back end
i'm get 10 mil on some back and we're
both gonna make bank people tune into it
we'll put a big youtuber on it
jake which we'll get to jake
and then you'll get money but i'm not
going to neck you out i'm not going to
hit you the head i'm going to go to the
body you're cool with the body i'm cool
with the body
mike tyson comes in shape roy not in
shape oh kitties oh my god whatever
yes but it was just like you know i've
called it from the jump man and i'm i'm
not a
hater like i hope they make a ton of
money but it just ain't for me man like
yeah
it was just some [ __ ] like again how
long are we gonna pretend
that this [ __ ] is dope that wasn't dope
man
that wasn't cool it will really piss me
off and
uh you can jump in anytime uh the two
minute rounds so two minute rounds
you take a minute off of of of like a
round
it's it's so significant because two
minutes you can spend one minute just
like okay trying to figure out the last
minute you can go hard then you go back
to your corner a minute rest
you like you re-energize it's not a real
fight that's women's boxing no
disrespect it's also amateur boxing
amateur boxing golden gloves is two
minute rounds yeah really but yeah but
no i don't know anything about it okay
but i'm just saying let me play devil's
advocate here and this is where i was
actually
i thought so the good things about the
the take my take away from it
the production was dope it's well lit
the way they
the the camera angles zoom dog coming
out we'll get this knit we'll get to
snoopy
we will get to snoop a loop i didn't
hear below get to scoop a little
snoop lion is what they call them snoop
lion um
so the the production value was high i
dug all that but it was just
um so with the two minute rounds yeah to
me
boxing's like this the trend of boxing's
like this because the kids aren't into
it
because if you're let's say you're a 12
year old kid yeah my son right now he'll
be five
in february if i turn on the tv and i
have him watch
earl spence danny garcia to the best
boxers on the planet
so dope yeah i can't wait either we'll
be on stage or whatever so dope
what we'll have in the green room okay
it's a great fight two of the best
incredible
yes yeah if you show that to kids in
elementary school
and then you show them a ufc fight
you show them any name any big name to
connor versus empori
not one kid is going to tune in that
boxing match it's just not exciting
yeah and there's 12 rounds it's three
minutes 12 rounds they don't get started
to round six really
yeah like they like boxing the sweet
science
yeah they warm up they figure each other
out it's like those first rounds are
feeling out processed no one's really
throwing blows they take you know then
six through twelve it gets
hard so to me the eight uh
two minute rounds dog if they did that
like if earl spence and dan garcia did
that
you getting action-packed [ __ ] fights
if you only have that short amount of
time dudes are going to throw dude
especially that heavyweight think of
heavyweight so you thinking this so you
think you should do it that way what
i think they should consider yeah two
men around have you ever
have you ever been watch the box and
find like
damn i wish there's 10 more rounds no
never well hold on yes me well i guess
i'm wild or fury maybe okay
when he got knocked down my only thing
is as soon as boxing ends i'm like thank
god
unless there's like a javonte davis
fight with his knockout yeah if it's
like
going like after 12 not once have i been
like god damn oh sure is more rounds so
you text me during the lomachenko and
lopez fight you said it was a great
fight
right if it were longer rounds would you
have been mad at it
because they was the action was starting
to pick up i was good what
i was good i was satisfied yeah like
there's there it's very rare in boxing
like damn i wish there's more
okay but when there's like when you're
on the 10th they're like [ __ ] thank god
there's only two left dog
certain fighters it's a lot like it's
just a lot you really think they really
don't start fighting till six
so it's kind of this weird like they
take it you know the feeling out process
yeah yeah it's really them just you know
not blowing their wad not blowing their
heads
when you look at like floyd connor like
you know he he
just was taking rounds off till he runs
off and then turn on destroyed him
yeah but imagine if you went hey you're
doing you're doing four two minute
like floyd ain't feeling them out no you
know we would just get in they're like
yeah what's up doug
it would be a different it would be well
you know women's boxing is too many
rounds
bro i just thought you said you don't
feel like eating you said you literally
said that couple of minutes but
you know what you can always eat i can
imagine i don't feel like you know but i
can always
my thing is from that i was like they
went by fast i'm like man
you know it gave tyson a chance to kind
of get going a little bit there yeah
i don't know listen there's a lane for
it and it's all good and i hope they
make a ton of [ __ ] money
and i hope they can do it till they're
100 years old but it's it's just
you know for when i watched that main
event and i scrambled back over and
watched the main event the ufc
and just like dude come on it depends
what frame of mind you're in
okay because i watched so much fighting
i went in thinking even though i knew
the rules
i was like because i think maybe because
jake paul starts nate robinson
yeah so you're like damn this [ __ ] for
real yeah and then you know so you know
how long were there rounds three minutes
because that was a real fight yeah that
was the same thing yeah yeah got it that
wasn't
that and i actually what do you think of
nate robinson starts you know he did no
sparring
i know which is stupid by the way and
you just i think it's good for the game
because you have
so many celebrities being like damn i'd
love to bo preacher we love preachers oh
yeah we love preaching
a lot of people should watch that and
like oh that's what could happen no no
that's what should happen exactly if you
don't train properly if you don't have
experience
fight again snoop said it it was the
best play made all night
uh you made a lot of great points well
he made one great point
but um he can't play he took he took
over the
entire analyst booth and it was fun at
first but
we'll get to it but so you know he says
you can play basketball you can play
football
you can't play fighting and i think it's
very good for these celebrities and
other ex-athletes to learn like
dog that that's what happens man yeah
like that's typically what will happen
if you get in there and look
paul uh jake paul is not a reef not a
real fighter
he's just exactly that's the the thing
that the exactly he's not
technically he doesn't come from the sk
same background as a box
no but for the past three years he's
been training like a probiotic
he takes it more serious he has though
his he has the muscle memory
like that check hook that's tough to
teach dude that's muscle
that's him of hours in the boxing gym
when the guys rush in to check hookah do
to knock him out
like that's no random punch that's not a
lucky shot like that's
technical [ __ ] dude so let me ask you
this and it goes back to those
your two minute rounds would you be more
you should say a celebrity should learn
but that you were entertained with that
nate paul
uh nate robinson and paul fight did you
see my tweet am i
he was like yeah i saw that i said i
said but i said boxing heads gonna be
real mad when they realize
jake paul is the most entertaining boxer
on the card so is that a lie
no it wasn't a lie that was the truth
yeah people get so upset
there it is right here was there actual
like so like
logan paul shout out yeah praise them oh
look at that i disagree i should have
had you commentate fam
yes and i'll probably
here's my thing and i'll probably work
with logan and jake but the thing is
is shut up ah and i get what the
the analyst team was doing because
they're paying the check i'm not the guy
that's gonna
suck him off yeah i'm a tyson fan but
he's not my goat not even close
he's not my top five he's ever been i
love that he's just not
a lot of people i said that rick beau
lennox lewis evander holyfield
all better careers all better well you
have george foreman
oh you're talking about heaven no i'm
taught anybody like when you when you
talk about heavyweights yes
heavyweights he's not my top five
because you didn't even say linda's
lewis you didn't even get i said lance
lewis you did oh yeah
so that's your top five ready bow i mean
you muhammad ali george foreman i mean
frazier like
to me they're all better he's the most
scary guy at the time
yeah but name the best dude he's beat
spanx come on man
come on you got a point when you look at
it he was so scary we all grew up with
that being scared
when you look at tyson when you look at
level of competition any time he faced a
real dude
who he couldn't punk like evander
holyfield like riddick beau he lost but
also we got so it's like how can that be
your
greatest of all time well also like like
when you talk about grace all times in
any sport when you talk to you know we
talk about khabib he fought dudes who
are
[ __ ] really good dominated them yeah
anytime dominated they tried william
dominates them
you talk about goats jon jones dude he
had his
share of dudes that were like gus finn
justice big just as talented
dominated him dc dominated them
you you go through michael jordan as i
when he faced isaiah thomas or he faced
any of these dudes
dominates dude so if it's tough for me
for the argument of mike tyson being the
most dominant it's like
not really how about that when i get off
stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song